This? Okay.
Wow.
Me prancing and going sick.
Where are my wheels?
That was a stretch.
That was like a random dinosaur noise I wanted to make.
Hi. Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Turns out I can actually be a lot louder than I first anticipated.
My dad had no idea I streamed.
So I finished the stream and I went back down.
And I got off again.
And obviously he was off at that point.
And I was like, oh yeah, no, I enjoyed my stream.
Sadly I was motion sick.
And he was like, huh?
He streamed.
And I'm like, yeah, you didn't hear me.
I was like having a carry on and stuff.
But apparently he never heard nothing.
So, well, I guess I can be a hell of a lot louder.
And I will because yesterday I was like, I was ill as anything though.
Thank you for understanding.
I was so freaking ill.
Yes, we're going to play this little silly goofy thing.
It's called will you press the button?
Basically, apparently it gives you scenarios and either you press it or not.
And then it'll give you statistical percentages of who pressed it and who didn't.
Is he a heavy sleeper?
Yes, I thought because of the flight he basically passed out for ages.
But yeah, we went to the shops and we got food.
He was so mad at me for the food that I had in my fridge or the lack thereof.
He was pissed.
And I showed him the short that I made of Sheebie.
So on my channel there's a short.
And I'm like, if I had a willy, I know that Sheebie's design is a 10 out of 10.
And I showed it to him.
And he was like, oh, I didn't want to hear you talking about a willy.
And I was like, damn, Papa Cuttle said no to food.
Which is absolutely mean and both funny.
But I showed him Amy's rats.
I was like, all right, this is Amy.
She has rats and they're adorable.
And he found them quite funny.
Esteban is his favorite rat for yanking all this stuff.
Because there's a one point like Amy's doing something.
And I think it's the burger one.
And he's like, OK, we have a burger here and then Esteban yanks it.
And she's like, we have half a burger.
Please tell your dad to try and force you to enjoy.
Oh, but he's cooking me steak.
We went to the shops and he's like, right, you're eating better.
What do you need?
And I was like, well, I kind of need a steak, I guess.
And we've got chicken to marinate overnight.
I've never marinated a chicken before.
That sounds like a marinate chicken.
Like, no, I've not got time to marinate chicken
and put it in a Ziploc bag.
I had to buy Ziploc bags for the first time.
I was like, what do I even need these for?
The less he knows the better.
Oh, no, he finds it hilarious what I do.
Oh, my hell, yeah.
Marinate.
It's good to see you having a good time with your dad.
Yeah.
I was telling him about how you guys call him father-in-law.
And he was like, oh, I don't know if he's going to write a letter for me to say on stream.
I'll see if he wants to do it.
He mentioned leaving you as a message.
And I was like, do you mean like a physical one?
Or like, what do you mean?
Like, I need to take down the transcript.
But he was like, no, no, I'll write.
Oh, he approves of you guys.
Oh, he approves of you all right.
I was basically like, oh, so they're called Reflings.
Because he still says Radish Boys, which is an old name.
But yes, he's definitely three weeks of real food.
Your body isn't going to know it.
Literally, I'm going to have so many bill movements.
But yes, today's just a chill stream.
I'm just meming away.
We're going to enjoy just, just chatting, doing our thing.
There's no major rush for anything.
And I believe Sheebie is on today.
So we'll redirect into her.
It's nice and chill.
And then I'm going back to Charlotte.
He's going to invite us for a mission next week.
Oh, my dad's know the camping tape.
Just say, what is my dad?
Maybe I'll walk.
Maybe a bit of the foodie.
She's doing a member streamer for a regular streamer.
Okay, well, someone else is getting redirected, isn't it?
And it's not Sheebie.
I'm sure there's someone we can find.
I need to buy some more bait and tackle.
What's this gamer tag?
Oh, my God.
Oh, he was talking to me about gaming because I was telling him,
like, oh, I got to play cameo again.
And he was like, you know what?
Cameo was hitting my dad's got stronger accent.
So he's like, oh, by the Pope.
Mama, I vanquished a possum last night for you.
He lived by the saying, you are what you eat.
And he was eating roadkill.
Strong enough.
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh, you eat?
Wait, you killed a possum?
I'm glad to hear he approves,
but I'm going to work so not going to be interacting for now.
Oh, don't worry if you have to work.
Enjoy work.
Make sure you hydrate.
Thank you, Broly Legend for the tit.
Orvon Biscotti.
Thank you for the super chat.
You killed a possum?
You didn't have to perish him.
He was just freaking doing it.
Papa Cuddles is going to get stream sniped, honestly.
Nah.
Are possum bad in America?
You're not supposed to perish the wildlife.
You're supposed to feed it.
I had, I fed the birds yesterday.
Wah.
I kid you not.
There must have been a hundred birds in that garden.
Listen, during work.
Well, I'm not going to be acting up too much, so you probably can.
This is probably the most say so I'm going to be for the next three weeks.
Although I do have bad news.
I don't think I can do that ASMR stream.
That's planned tomorrow.
I don't think I can actually do any ASMR stream for three weeks.
I can literally hear the walls reverberating right now from my dad snoring.
So yeah, I really don't want my dad's fart while he sleeps memorized.
Clipped and shipped.
As hilarious as that would be.
That's rather weird to explain.
Like, oh, dad, by the way.
Someone clipped your fart whilst I was like streaming ASMR.
Yeah, I don't really want that to go down in history.
So I think we're going to pause on ASMR for three weeks.
I know how boring.
Oh, and the complete sabotage.
But obviously I will make it up when my dad goes.
I will keep you up to date when we're going to do it.
It's all good.
But seriously, okay, if you can't do it, it must have been the wind.
Honestly, the freaking walls are vibrating from how intense his snoring is.
Old man fart ASMR.
Honestly, imagine me try to be all cute in that.
And then you just hear like meh in the background like, okay, you're done.
Make sure you hide all your figures well.
Oh, I fucking made sure that was done.
The perfect set up for don't wake up appearance.
My dear sibling ace.
Hey, yo, you thinking like a pin pal here?
Chill three weeks and then endurance marathon after marathon after marathon.
Yeah, pretty much that's the plan.
It all looks good to me.
Well, surely that was a lot of stuff that even the thought of it is like, oh, no.
I'm having me cup of tea.
Wait, you need to try and be cute.
Well, so whenever I do like ASMR, I feel a lot of pressure.
Actually, like when I do it live, I don't know how to explain it.
I don't get like stage fright or anything.
But I feel like with ASMR, I can't really be my goblino self.
It normally does end up me just straight up talking to you by the end of it.
But I feel like I have to try and choose my words carefully to not ruin the ambiance
or what's going on type thing.
I'm not a pin pal.
I'm loyal to my mate.
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I never doubted you for a second.
What?
ASMR, your Scottish girlfriend brought you to meet her parents
and she's trying to relax you while her dad snores louder than a motorcycle on the net.
No, because it's true.
It's actually true.
Like, I was gonna play Ring Fit next week.
Next week, I'm playing a lot of Nintendo games
because I found my Ildeado.
I'm gonna...
I don't know what kind of choke hold that Sakuya game,
the fruit game on Nintendo has on VTubers,
but I'm joining the ranks and seeing what that game's all about.
I swear to God, if I'm about to spend,
I don't know how much it costs,
if I'm about to spend a ridiculous amount of money on this little Nintendo fruit game
and it's absolutely the most piss-borne thing I've ever played,
all VTubers unanimously are getting bent over my knee and spanked
because you all make that game look so addicting.
Everyone in their nan was playing that game
and you all made it look so addicting.
So I swear, I swear.
If I pay three quid, three whole quid,
someone says in that game's piss,
everyone's getting spanked.
Everyone unanimously, okay?
Johnny's 100% getting addicted to it as much as Belchro.
Is that actually becoming a VTuber right now?
Okay, I'll spank the VTubers,
but I'll ink you guys from behind
if it was you guys that said that it was a good game, okay?
I never got the sucker hype.
I don't even know how to say it.
Three quid to US dollar.
I don't, er, fucking six dollars.
I think, well, the old conversion rate was great,
British pounds to dollars was two,
the other way about one to two.
I always said it like,
Get that watermelon.
Aye, so we're going to play that next week.
The Streams Dave game's going to be Mario Kart.
Who goes there? Identify yourself.
And then I was going to do Ring Fit as well
because I need some exercise.
I walked to the shops with my dad.
Motherfucker, I was telling him to slow down
and I'm like, fucking hell, I'm a gamer.
You need to relax, dad.
Like, relax, I'm in no rush.
I got to show my magpies
and there's also a crow I am now feeding.
So I got to show him that and he was like,
oh, damn, that crow's pretty badass.
And I'm like, yeah, me and dad both have the bird autism.
We're like, yeah, birds are cool.
I'm like, yeah, yeah.
Honestly, we're the same damn person.
We were like, watch Star Trek last night
and I have something very adorable.
I'm going to cry if I think about it too much.
My mom found my childhood toy
and I'm going to take a picture and you can all see it.
It needs a big wash, but his name is Charlie
and he's a wee monkey and I absolutely adore him.
So, yeah, I was like, oh, did you bring me any books?
Because last time my dad visited me,
he brought me books all my family.
I asked my family, like, oh, if you have any favourite books,
please just give them to my dad and he'll give them to me.
And he was like, no, sorry, no books this time.
And I'm like, oh, no, that's fine, that's fine, don't worry about it.
And then he's like, oh, but there is one thing though.
And he whips out Charlie from behind them
and I was like, you know if I wasn't so violently motion sick,
I'll right now, I would burst out in tears.
I have not seen my childhood Teddy since I was about 12 or something.
And I sent my mom a text and I was like, you found Charlie
and she's not replied to me yet, but oh my God,
I've got my childhood toy and I love them to smithereens.
And I remember he's got a little toy, he's got a speaker in him
and he goes, because he's a monkey.
They love monkeys. I love gorillas.
Shout out to any viewer named Charlie right now, literally.
Charlie's not a cat. Charlie's a monkey.
Return to monkey.
But I'll take a little photo of him
and I can show you my childhood toy.
Maybe someone from the UK might have a Charlie too.
It's Charlie on your bed.
No, I have to put Charlie away in case Gimli and Vigil destroy him.
I don't want any trouble. I don't want any trouble.
My uncle did a funny, he gave me a toy monkey as a kid
and told me his name was Spank.
You guys spank the monkey.
Oh wait, no, that's, you guys taught me,
that doesn't mean what I think it means.
Monka? Monka? Are you okay?
I feel that passing down a childhood bear to my kid.
Oh, honestly, I'm so happy with Charlie.
I was like, honestly, if I didn't feel so violently sick,
I would have burst out crying there.
Yes, I remember what it means though,
but I forgot what I meant yesterday.
I'm sorry, I didn't know.
I didn't know any better.
Okay, great.
I actually played this game before I end up just turning into a rant,
a rant, a ramble about everything and anything.
Pardon me, boys.
Right.
Oh, I can also make that short about how much money I earn.
I was explaining to my dad, like, oh,
I'm going to make this short because I'm showing him what,
he knows what YouTube shorts are,
but I was just showing him like, oh, because I'm a,
I was like, all right, you're getting dusted upon the world of VTubers,
and I showed him like Rin Penrose's stuff,
and I was like, see how it's all like insider knowledge.
Like, people are genuinely interested in the ins and outs
of like, how being a VTuber is.
And I was saying to him, like, I'm going to show my income for the month,
and he was like, is that wise?
Like, aren't people going to think you're bragging?
And I'm like, no, it's not for bragging.
It's to show like, this is how much you, you know, you can earn.
Fucking put your head down and, you know,
work your booty off type thing.
And I was like, a lot of it is also, you have to remember,
YouTube generates like free money when people watch VODs back
and the ASMR videos, for example.
But anyway, shut the fuck up, Johnny.
No one cares.
You'll get a short soon about how much I earned in my first month of it all.
I've a Gen 2 update.
Five.
One of them is a very unique design.
A female concept artist.
The chick concept artist is giving me her batch by August 1st.
We've just received the second one from her.
And we are looking fucking solid.
That's all I'm saying.
Sorry, I just sucked my finger because I opened up a can of cola.
But five designs have been...
What is going on with my cola?
Is there all exploding recently?
Unique in a good way?
Oh, unique in a good way.
I don't think there's like absolutely nothing where someone's like,
this person looks like this person.
No, get to fuck.
And then two, there's no one that's got the same bloody lore.
I can tell you that much.
Coca-Cola for Gen 3.
Although the concept artist was fucking pranking me, man.
It goes horse.
I'm like, no, absolutely not.
And it goes unicorn.
No, absolutely not.
Do not fucking turn around and give me a bloody unicorn.
I swear, God, I was getting raging.
But the female concept artist, she's giving me too.
I look very adorable.
I'm just waiting.
No, no fucking horse confirmed.
No horse, no unicorn.
Donkey.
Mule, you guys are such trolls.
I'll spoil a stream that's coming up.
I'm drawing your shitty suggestions for Gen 2 live on MS Paint.
We're doing that not next week, but the week after the first one.
So you guys can literally write what you want and I'm going to draw it live.
And then I'll show you what your line-up's going to look like.
I'm going to take a screenshot.
And then next year, when they actually come out, I'm going to be like,
hmm, I wonder whose suggestions were better.
Mine are yours.
Who goes there?
Pegasus.
Oh, no.
But show me a roly-poly vetiver.
She's going to draw a million slime girls.
Honestly, I'm going to be like, what color do you want the slime girl?
Pick a color.
Emu.
She'd have to be Aussie if it was an Emu.
We get to comment on your drawing.
Oh, you can annihilate my drawing skills.
I don't have any.
Literally, the title of the stream is like drawing Gen 2 suggestions,
but I never learned to draw.
I never put those down.
Although that would be a fun idea.
All the other girls have like fucking capabilities to doodle or doosh it.
I'm going to have to tell them like,
hey, go have some fun streams.
Emu couldn't be Aussie after the war.
Cephalopod.
Vetiver when?
Kangaroo girl on Alpaca.
And Alpaca, no.
Right, when we actually do this,
the whole reason we're here today,
your doodles are cute.
Did you like the DEMPA birthday card on Twitter?
Oh my god, I can be a real streamer.
Please remember to like and subscribe,
even though I've not done the thing I said I was going to do.
Smile.
A honey badger.
Honey badger, don't give up.
Giraffe with that long neck?
Absolutely not.
Okay, you can change your physical appearance in any way at any time,
including swapping genders,
but you will never be able to look the same way twice.
I feel like that is like so minuscule.
Like it could be like, yeah,
I want an extra freckle on my butt cheek.
Like, I feel like that's so minuscule,
it's not even necessary.
I'd press, yeah, I'd press the crap out of that.
Do you know how much money I could make on only fans
with this ability?
Literally, I'm pressing the shit out of that.
Yeah, I was, I think these people have overthunk it by far.
27% have overthunk it.
Literally, you could be like, yeah,
I want a freckle in between my toes.
That's different, okay?
They played themselves.
Okay?
100% would press, no brainer.
This could be exploited to basically rule the world.
You have the ability to cure cancer with touch,
but you will die of cancer.
See, now, there's no...
Oh my god, I can...
Oh my god, that's a white one, guys.
I can open them up.
So, it says you'll die of cancer,
but it doesn't give a timeline.
And I'm not being funny.
Odds are, you actually do perish from cancer
the older you get.
Other than Alzheimer's.
Alzheimer's will fucking grab your brain
and shake it real good and make it full of protein
so it doesn't function and you stop eating, basically.
Yeah, see, because it doesn't specify die immediately,
I'm like, I could probably get a good solid 80 years
on this planet before the microplastics just annihilate me.
Until it's over for me and all the lead and the clothes and that.
I think sacrifice for the gain of others as well
is quite a noble thing.
Like, you know, my life is never going to amount to anything,
so if I could just cut about in the hospitals for a bit,
sure, fuck it, press that shit.
Oh wow, 40% said no.
St. Strawny, let him know.
Whatever comforts you, okay?
Whatever comforts you.
Altruistic question.
Cure everyone else but die a few years later.
Yeah, I feel like, because my life ain't going to be, you know,
about on general modification.
Delicious lead and microplastic lunchables.
Okay, sandy clothes is real.
Every other holiday, you know, never get celebrated again.
If, okay, that's definitely not the dad's up,
I guess I'll open them up.
I mean, like, oh, my dad sleeps through everything.
My dad who's literally slamming the cupboards right now.
Okay, Santa Claus is real,
but every other holiday, you know, does they get celebrated?
What are their other holidays?
Valentine's Day, you could be romantic any day of the week
to me, Refland.
Santa spawns capitalistic.
Santa Claus is actually just a capitalistic front
to part with more of your money and put yourself in debt
to the credit card companies.
I will not press that button.
Fuck you.
Damn straight.
That's right, my people rise up.
We identify against the capitalist pigs of society.
How dare you?
Okay, all food tastes twice as good,
but you're permanently constipated.
Oh, no. Wait a minute.
I really like food though.
Oh, no.
Did I get to relieve myself with my booty?
My wee douche, my wee pot douche?
No, it's not worth it. I mean, you're always constipated anyway.
Yeah, I was going to say, like, I mean,
this is literally me right now.
I really enjoy food, so I think I already have enhanced taste points.
And then, like, if ever, you know, get constipated,
I'm just like, oh, just squish some water on my boot.
That's as simple as.
Time to break out the colossal thing.
Wait, don't you just implode you would die out of the food?
I don't think I need it, actually.
I think food's already enhanced for me.
I will not. I will refrain, because I don't want to be full.
Oh, wow. Okay.
74% agreed.
Mmm.
Damn straight.
You save the world and make it a better place,
but you go down in history as a bad person?
I mean,
if you save the world and make it a better place,
again, this is the nation and good of the people,
but if you go down as a bad person in history,
I mean, think of how much history gets lost to time.
Like, name one fact in the 1300s.
Go. Like, you cannae off the top of your head.
History continues to develop,
and people are forgotten, and that's just how life is.
It's not a big deal to be forgotten,
and if you're remembered as a bad person,
guess what?
Every time someone dies,
the percentage of people that know you and are aware of you
are just so unlikely.
You know?
So don't worry about being remembered as a baddie, okay?
Save the planet, my final message.
Goodbye.
Will you press the button?
You will get super ability to read minds.
I can already do that with the reeflings.
If you read their mind for too long,
they know you're doing it.
Are you joking me? That's the best thing ever.
Can you know how much torment I can do with you?
I'd be like, I know what you're thinking, reefling.
And then you know that.
You know that I know that you're thinking of certain things.
How is that any bad?
That's not bad at all.
That is not bad.
Literally, whoever said 16%, come on.
Imagine how red your face is gonna go.
You're gonna be blushing.
You're just gonna love every second of it.
Mommy, please, I can't right now.
Can you control when you do it?
If so, 100% yeah.
Oh, hydration check.
I'm getting, getting, getting.
Oh.
I agree that some people's thinking my ball,
but I would never stop thinking with things.
What they're gonna do is stop thinking exactly.
Although apparently guys can like zone out really easily.
So maybe you just need to like zone out.
And I'm like, damn, I can't get nothing off of you.
I'd use that against you.
I could make,
I could think of things that would make you blush.
Okay, no, I'm here for it.
I'm here for that kind of reverse psychology.
You can perfectly torment someone
because you know what their picture in.
I'm zoning out right now.
I just started thinking of me.
Sorry, I'm dumb.
You can't get anything from my mind.
Oh, yeah.
Ah, yes, or nothing box.
Being empty-headed is just male superiority.
My strongest skill versus strong disassociation.
I cast this association.
Okay.
Everyone in your family would be taking care of
for the rest of their lives,
but you will be homeless for the rest of your lives.
I have terrible news for you,
but already take care of my family.
I will not press that button.
The fam are good.
Yeah, I was gonna say that's quite a high percentage.
I mean, I guess you could get around it
and being like Colin, you can be homeless.
You can never own a house under your legal name
if you want to get technical like that.
But already look after the fam,
so that was a much of a thing.
Homeless, no mad lifestyle in a van.
I've seen that.
The rise of people living in a van.
I've seen a few tech talks about it
and they're like, van life is good for me and all of that.
Yeah, homeless doesn't necessarily mean it in a house.
I agree, I agree.
Yeah.
And like obviously you have the freedom to bop about in that van
and you didn't have to pay like property taxes
or nothing on that bad boy
because you're living in a van.
I don't know how you get mail though.
Like if you need mail.
Okay.
You can bring any musician from the dead for one last show.
You won't be able to see and hear it.
I mean, if it's something for people to enjoy,
I don't always have to enjoy everything myself.
I can appreciate other people enjoying it.
You know?
If someone wants big beef oven to come out of the ground,
go for it.
You know?
I'm not going to ruin the night for someone else
just because I can't even get the goods of it.
Like relax.
Why would you say no?
There's literally no downside.
I mean, you could sync up on,
like literally you can have headphones in
and sync up the music to what it's supposed to be.
Relax.
Why is everyone so selfish?
That's a shame.
Imagine they off themselves and they were forced,
they off themselves and they're forced to come back.
Oh wait.
Did beef oven take his life?
Beethoven?
I don't know.
Monkers.
Meatloafs.
You go back in time and change one thing in history,
but you remain to the timeline.
You return to your timeline at any given moment.
Wait.
So like in theory,
I could be 80 years old in the past
and then it puts me back here.
I kind of be AA.
It'd be like,
Reflings.
Do you like gilf?
Do you like gilfs?
I'd take two-third.
I don't think I can hit that.
I'm like,
sorry,
but I need to be with the Reflings.
Born too late to,
I don't know,
C-sutton.
Born too early to C-sutton in the future.
Born at the right time.
I don't know.
Born at the right time to have my Reflings.
I'm not pressing.
I'm not touching anything with the timeline.
I'm keeping it the way it is.
I like this timeline.
I want to stay on it.
I want to be with my Reflings.
I got,
I got the happy ending.
Okay.
Take care of Granny.
Would you love me with Granny Strongzo?
Oh,
would the sweetie,
would,
oh wait,
I don't know why I'm fucking turning English.
Oh,
would the sweetie like Sa Sweetie?
Yeah.
You want to suck on my hard boiled sweet day?
After you and three friends get kidnapped,
Wilson,
you're in trouble and held hostage.
One of the nappers decides to let you go,
but you have to choose which one of your friends get,
um,
by what,
if you don't choose,
both will die.
Oh no,
I'm not doing none of that.
I'm not doing that.
You do not put your friends to death.
That's crazy.
I'm not even,
I'm not even participating in this.
Um,
if it results in death,
I'm,
I'm not touching it.
That's,
will they both die?
Wait,
if I click the button,
they both die?
No.
Yeah.
So I did that right.
Surely I did that right.
Uh,
hopefully I did that right.
I don't know.
Right, hold on.
How'd you say?
Shawnee killed everyone.
Honestly.
Jokes on you,
I only have,
I don't have two friends.
Wait,
if you bring one friend,
do you beat the system?
You both get away,
scot-free.
That was worded awfully.
Okay.
Thank goodness.
Cause I was like,
damn,
I have not woken up yet.
Right.
You will receive a lifetime supply of meals
from your favorite restaurant,
but you will lose the sense
of taste and smell.
That defeats the entire
purpose of enjoying meals
from your favorite restaurant.
Hi,
from the dead,
can you use that
bring back a dead person button
for the next one?
Thank you.
Sorry,
son.
But you would lose
your sense of taste and smell.
This is redundant.
That's not an option.
That's redundant.
You have negated the effects
of even pressing the damn thing.
No point in pressing it.
I'll just pay for the meals myself.
Okay,
I'll just work extra hard
so I can feed myself.
God damn.
That,
what if they're very nutritious meals?
I mean,
no longer having to pay for food
sounds like a dub.
Honestly,
true.
Texture and,
I mean,
I didn't even put my tongue
on a lasagna
in between the milty cheese
and be like,
yeah,
that satisfies me.
No,
that satisfies me is the taste
and combination
of swallowing.
Okay.
My,
my tongue might be
an exploratory sense,
but like,
I need something
to work off of
when it comes to food.
Right.
All new born children
from here on
will be born
perfect
with immunity
to all diseases
incredibly intellect,
incredible intellect
and good locks.
But
all single people
over the age of 30
will die
instantaneously.
No.
Relax.
It's,
it's okay to have
natural selection.
Look,
I'm sorry.
I said it.
It's okay to have
natural selection
within the populace.
It's perfectly normal.
It comes with nature.
Like,
I mean,
relax.
Why is it 30?
They decided the wall.
They literally said,
hags out.
They said,
lollipops in hags out.
No,
I'm not pressing the button.
Relax.
The eugenics button.
Stop.
That's crazy.
I'm 29.
So press it.
Hag.
Literally,
they said hags out.
Relax.
Lollipops in.
Okay.
Everyone's in.
Fine.
That was a bizarre button.
Some of these are getting
rather,
rather crazy.
No hags.
Hag discrimination.
Me dead.
Hollow life would not
survive such a loss
to their audience.
Wait,
is hollow life full
of hags?
No way.
I don't even think
we have one hag.
I don't think
Are we the youngest
agency?
Wait,
is hollow life full of hags?
No.
A lot of VTuber fans
are third plus two.
The audience.
Oh,
the audience.
Sorry.
I thought they sent the VTuber.
I was like,
oh my God,
are we like a really young agency
compared to the
thingy?
They're all hags
with high voices.
Hag love.
Karuna's 40.
No, she's not.
You're,
you're pulling my leg.
No one's 40
in hollow life.
30 ain't,
no,
that's hag life.
What are people smoking?
You and she be on high?
No,
well,
you think I'm 30?
I'm not over 30.
I'm not being funny.
I act like I'm over 30.
You think I'm a hag?
Me more she be?
I don't think any of us are hags.
Kenda.
Oh my God.
Danny,
I'm over there.
You think I'm over there?
Can't wait until you're a gilf.
I literally,
a gilf gliss go granny.
That alliteration though.
You're done.
A bit.
Oh my God.
A 20-something year old
with five kid does sound a bit crazy though.
Okay.
Thank you.
It's over for that refling.
Mauds,
give that refling a backshot.
Old lady's 20.
At minimum,
you're older than me.
Hmm.
A bet face connect is the youngest average talent,
to be honest.
Hmm.
What's wrong with being over 30?
Absolutely nothing,
but I don't think I act like I'm,
I feel like 30 is when you mature.
I'm not over 30.
Wasn't 25 hack?
Or expired Xmas cake?
What?
It's just new terminal,
expired Christmas cake.
Who is walking around
calling VTubers expired Christmas cakes?
You need to come back
and explain yourself for that comment right now.
What does that even mean?
A Christmas cake?
Oh,
that,
it's a common term.
Matureing is for vegetables.
You have to,
oh my God.
Hag older than me,
therefore the age goes up every year.
Okay, that's funny.
Wait, Christmas cake is a term?
No,
that's hilarious.
I've not heard of that.
You might as well just start calling people prunes
while you're at it.
Oh, you're a wrinkly old prune.
What age is that?
Oh, oh, it's 20.
What?
Like,
that is hilarious.
A Christmas cake is a Japanese term
for a woman past her prime.
That's shocking.
That's,
that's,
fermented VTuber agency.
That is hilarious.
I am closing down VLR
to open that up right now.
It's just dedicated to hags only.
Imagine getting called a reason.
Honestly,
Shawnee is the least wee VTuber
I've ever seen.
True.
I'm a gamer over a weeb.
Does that mean I'm shunned?
Am I shunned?
But I do want to watch enemies with you.
Actually, that's a side note.
I do want to watch enemies with you guys.
So,
there'll be a wave three confirmed.
Gen three full of hags.
I mean,
well, it can't be gen two
unless you want a hag and a lollipop
because there's two lollipops.
VLR lasts long enough
it'll become a hardcore.
Honestly,
I mean,
if you guys didn't know,
the girls will renew their contract
in May 2025
and as an incentive
to stay on,
the split goes to 85.15
and we also purchase them
an alternative outfit
they can ask for what they want
and we'll pay the costs for it.
So yeah,
if you watch JoJo's,
I'll stop by watching right now.
Oh, isn't JoJo's long?
I mean,
I'm talking like 12-episode stuff.
we can even watch a bit of Bentay
if you want.
Like, calm down.
Yes.
Lollibaba gen,
just all of them.
It depends.
It has various seasons.
If you think about it,
Hale is around for like seven years.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Is it that halo you were talking about?
Is my dress up darling possible?
Is it long?
12?
Yeah, like I'm talking like
we sit down for the day
and watch a 12-episode anime together.
That's what I want to do.
They said holo, not halo.
Oh, sorry!
Sorry.
I wasn't kidding when I said
I was a gamer.
I said it was a gamer, okay? I read Halo. I thought you were talking about Halo, the
hit video game, okay? Master Chief from Fortnite. Sorry. Sorry. Based in gamer build, honestly.
Right. You can get a ton of candy that you love. You'll never be able to read a book.
Oh no, I'm in a reading book. Sorry. I'm in a reading book. I've been enjoying reading
a few books. I will abstain from this button. I've been enjoying a good book. And I've
still not even read Lord of the Rings with you yet. Reading isn't for Mummy today and
this entire stream is about reading so it's not going well. I don't know what to replace
tomorrow's stream with yet. I don't know if I'll bring up the honey. I don't know if
you guys saw the schedule. I'm playing Honeycam Studios. That game used to have everyone in
a freaking grip. Ooh, we're going to do reading stream. Well, this is technically reading,
is it not? I'm reading chat and I'm reading, will you press the button? You want the bent
high stream tomorrow? Hmm. Wait, you said Lord of the Rings would be when you graduate.
Oh, did I? For the book? Okay, we're not reading Lord of the Rings anytime soon then. I still,
put me back in the ring, Chief. I still got it. I still got it, okay? I got that doll.
Let me back in the ring. Bunny Garden. It's no for me. It's no for me. I'll have a hunt
around and see if I can find a few shorter games. I just stopped being sad when I watched
Johnny. No pass on this. Okay, you can make all the world feel happy, but you become sad.
I become sad. Um, I don't think I can stream very well if I'm in a bad mood. A cheese, oh,
a chess blitz stream when? Um, there's a solid one here, you like that? What remains of Edith
Flint? I'm playing that in three weeks. I wrote that down because someone recommended it and
it was short. Already depressed, I'll push the button. Oh, I'll be fine. Nothing changes for
me, but the world gets better. Why not? Oh, no, I'm not that sad. I'm quite, I'm always quite
neutral or happy. I don't think it, wait, I don't, can I make you as happy if I'm depressed?
I don't know. I feel like I can't do it because if I'm depressed, I can't even stream. An actual
dilemma for once. This is probably the first one that I've actually had a dilemma with.
Have you played Sucker for Love? I have not. I can't be sad when watching you pass. Press the
button. I'm already at that stage. If Stroni was sad, I would be sad. Yeah, literally, I'd be
greeting over anything and making you guys upset. So no. Oh, wow, I'm in the minority. This is the
first question I've been in the minority. Wow. Oh, no, I couldn't be sad. I feel like I'd wrought
away, I'd waste away. Oh, no, that's the first one I failed where I don't, I'm not with the
majority. Oh, wait, what did I just do? Oops. Oh, sorry. I thought I was on the same one. I'm so
sorry. I thought I was on the same one. What did I say no to? Half Life 3 comes out, but you never
get to play it. And I said, no. Oops. Okay, let's actually do it. Sorry. The Byzantine
Empire is revived. What? What kind of question is that? What kind of question is this? Oh, my
god. I thought this is like a funny thing. Yeah. Oh, this is bizarre. How did that even get in?
Did they not review the submitted questions? What the fuck? That's bizarre. That's bizarre. We're
skipping, we're skipping this. We're not, this isn't a submission or anything of anything. What the
fuck? What the fuck? We're skipping. We're not even looking at the results. Okay. That was bizarre.
Anyway, unlimited supply of your favorite cereal for the rest of your life, but you can't have any
milk with it. This, people love submitting things that negate the benefit of the first one. Like,
here's the benefit. Oh, by the way, we're gonna negate it. Okay, so there's pointless then. There's
no point to it. Like, I'm lactose intolerant. Anyway, let's go. Press. I don't even use milk.
Water and cereal, it is. Don't ever speak for the rest of the stream. Don't make me ever think
about watery Cheerios. I don't want to think about watery Cheerios, okay? Okay, you're allowed to
speak, but don't do that again. Okay. Juice and cereal. What kind of juice? How do you put juice
in Cheerios? Substitute with yogurt. Time out that reflint. Never cook again.
Wait, we can give it to the people who need it. Oh, if it's boxed up, then sure, I'd donate that
stuff. I don't eat cereal anyway. Yeah, that's fine. We'll box it up and we'll give it to food
banks. I have no problem with that. I'm not fussed for cereal. It's just like sugary thingy anyway.
Wait, hold up. Is Cheerios your favorite? I like Honey Cheerios. I like Frosted Shreddies,
and I like Crunchy Knot. It's called Crunchy Knot in the UK. Stop laughing. Stop it Americans.
I know you're laughing right now. It's called Crunchy Knot. It's the name of the cereal.
It's not your sock, okay? It's not your crusty sock. It's called Crunchy Knot. It is. It's what
the cereal's called. Stop. That nut, oh man. Base, I love those Crunchy Knot. Laugh at her. No,
it's what it's called. My nuts a bit more chewy, sadly. You're right. It's our Crunchy Socks. I
was going to make the most disgusting ASMR. Someone tweeted something hilarious, and it was like a
crunchy sock, and I was like, I really want to make an ASMR of me munching, and it's like girlfriend
munches on your crusty sock ASMR at the bottom of your bed while you sleep or something like that,
and it's absolutely disgusting. Actually, I'm going to write that down before I forget. Write that down.
Write that down. Girlfriend munches on your crusty sock ASMR, and it's just me like, that's delicious,
and all of that, and I'm munching away. That's disgusting. No way, that's foul, but it's so funny.
It is foul. That's why I want to make it. Okay, you've become the funniest person on the planet.
You can only talk in jokes, and they're always Chuck Norris jokes. Again with the negation.
I'm going to need you to come up with abstract concepts that these two don't relate, but they're
on a level, whether that be philosophical, physical, some sort of same level. But Chuck Norris jokes
are funny. I can't even remember. Can we just go back to unbirth? You know what, you're done.
Are you saying Chuck Norris isn't funny? What's the Chuck Norris thing? I can't remember.
I've literally forgotten the Chuck Norris memes. Stroni's already the funniest person on the planet.
You stop that, you give me an ego. We all know women can't be funny.
I'm accidentally humorous. That's why I am. That's by accident. Does that make you the only person
on the planet? Chuck Norris jokes are really not. Chuck Norris doesn't eat honey. He chews bees.
Ah, right. Okay, I remember. I remember. I remember. I remember. Get on with the funniest.
The sin of greed is not here. Again, I'm going to say no. I don't know. I will not press. You
cannot tempt me, devil. But yeah. Oh, wow. Okay, majority vote there. Only 19%. We're like, yeah,
that's good. Okay, you become completely immortal. I don't like that. If humanity hasn't made it to
interstellar travel and sun has gone supernova, you will drift in space alone still. No,
absolutely not. See, the reason why I like vampires is because you know, if you've ever had enough,
you can just go to someone, go and do as a favor pal. See this bit of wood, go and just hammer it
through my chest. That'd be great pal. Just stay up, right? But this version, absolutely not. It's
the most horrific thing I have ever seen. Like vampire, you take it, you're crazy. Just jumping
to a black hole. A bit of cheeky spaghettification to solve the problem. Why not? Being stuck in
space doesn't sound so bad. There's no internet in space. Who wants to become immortal? Are you crazy?
Understand all truth of the universe but can never talk to others again. Well, good thing,
I know sign language. Boom. And I can write stuff down on paper. Boom. Press that,
motherfucker. Oh wait, how am I supposed to livestream? Would you guys still watch me if
the way I communicated was by doing, like, I like to do sign language and write stuff down?
Can I still make noises? It says talk. If I can still make noises, all you're gonna hear is like
just use a talk text to speech stream, morse code stream. I have no idea what I've just said
if I actually said anything. If TTS has a Scottish accent, I mean, I wouldn't understand you one bit
but sure. But imagine all of the conspiracy theories I can tell you about. Come on, that's like
unlimited content. Wait, how would we get ASMR? It would just be non-talking ASMR. So congrats to
the people that don't like talking ASMR. I got you covered. You press the button but the button
doesn't work. Go for it then. Wait, why did no one press that? She chose knowledge over us. No,
I'll give you the details, okay? Eh, no talking ASMR. I don't like it. You gain the power to stop
time as long as you want and as often as you want but while time has stopped, you age normally
and each time you restart, you age, bruv, again with the negation.
I mean, I guess it's optional. I can't imagine I'm up to anything but to skip six months of health
is insane though. You guys are saying easy press? You gain the power to stop time as long as you want.
What would I need to do with that? I mean, I guess if I had just all lined up at convention,
it'd be worth it. Nah, I don't think I like that. I guess if it's optional to have it as a back
pocket ability, like say you wear, I think someone said car crash there. Yeah, say if you knew you
were about to be in a car crash. Mugging the car crash? Okay. I'm pressing it because it's an optional
ability. You don't have to activate it but it could be life or death. So I'm actually not too
raging at it. You can ink with any women you want just by pointing at them and asking but you must
watch the notebook each time. This is just an OG, son. What's going on here? You guys, I'm pretty
sure that Snowberries just watched the notebook with icicle. Can we change this to a reflin instead?
You can have... Oh, I said the word sorry, I did. I just slapped my mouth there. If you heard that,
you can have... You can ink. Hey, Strani, never made me pointing at you but I need to ask you
something. We can already do this. Don't need to do that one more minute. That's all good. I
literally just smacked my mouth there. Right, let's just pretend this says refling. Thank you. I'll
take it. Thank you very much. Yeah, 60% said I. Well, Strani doesn't want to ink with me. No, because
it specifies every time you ink. Yeah, but with a partner. I mean, that could be the aftercare.
Oh, let's slap on the notebook. How long's the notebook? I've never seen it. I don't know what
it's about, to be honest. Apparently, refling's your in it. You're featured in it.
Strani, you just need to ask. I'd cry every time. It's too long. It's two hours.
It would be wild if the movie just flashed in your head during... Google says it's two hours and 10
minutes. Oh, that's quite a lot. Can't be aftercare. You need to watch before. But someone said it
makes you cry. You have an unlimited amount of cash, power, and good looks. But Justin Bieber is
your roommate for the rest of your life. He acts like a massive douchebag. Is this... How old is
this website? Is this like an old-ass question? Do you remember the hate that Justin Bieber used to
get? Oh my god. Mail on stream. Literally not having that. Like, I feel like... Right, this is just
me. I feel like if you never work towards something, like, you never get that satisfaction of trying
hard and getting it to pay off. Like, if it's just handed to you, so is but. This is just me. If it's
just handed to you, you've got nothing to work towards. Like, now don't get me wrong. Capitalism,
bad and all that. But if you had unlimited money, what experiences do you get other than making
poor people miserable and, like, squandering over, like, falling out your feet to try and get a tip
from you type thing? Like, is that what gives, you know, billionaire? I would literally... You know,
actually, if I had unlimited money, I think I'd bring back the arts. I want architecture. I want
sandstone architecture back in. I want rid of this new age buildings. I want historical, beautiful
features. I want the arts back. Have you seen the churches made in the 15th century? Stunning,
beautiful, still standing. And then churches today are, like, ugly. I'm here for the culture. When we
play Civilian Civilization 5, I'm here for the culture, okay? I want culture. I like culture,
okay? Done with modern architecture, exactly. Using limited money to lobby every Congress,
parliament on earth to do your bidding. Now you're talking, like, a real refling. I like that, I like
that. Holy Bacus, bring back past architecture. Cultural victory, reject modern return to Ziggurats.
Cultural victory. No way to get rid of him means you can kill him. You can kill him?
Actually, yeah, he doesn't have to be alive. And if I have unlimited power, I mean, no one's gonna
find out. He acts like a mess and... Oh, there's no way to get rid of him. Oh, no, sorry. It's not worth it.
It's not worth it, okay? You can choose to save the life of any loved one or friend at will,
but they will no longer remember who you are. I don't... I'm not one for meddling with nature. I
find it quite rather... I think when you're, you know, I don't believe in, like, fate or, like,
you know, you're destined for this or that. But I'm not a fan of, like, Trump and nature. Like,
I'll let nature do its course, you know? I'd press it for you. Oh, Riefling! What the...
Don't say that. Are you trying to make us cry? It's like first thing in the morning. Are you
trying to make us cry? Oh, my God. I press it to love someone. You sometimes you have to be a stranger.
Well, literally, I don't know if you guys remember Harry Potter where Hermione had to
get her parents to forget or I'm like, oh, my God. I hope she can reverse that.
Um, Spider-Man already did that. I doubt my friends are getting into many life or death,
but I could re-meet them and check they existed. I don't know. Imagine saving a parent. Oh,
it didn't sound... Oh, I don't know if I can even speak on that because I've not lost a parent.
I'd probably feel way different at a later date, but
that route forgetting you as well is like really... It's not... Yeah, I'm not sure. I'm not touching
that. I'm not touching it. Well, yeah, I'm in the minority with that one. That scares me. That
kind of stuff scares me. That one was a hard one. That was not an easy one.
Johnny, I would also press it for you. I would make you happy even if I meant I could never...
You never knew who I was. That's so sad though. Are you trying to make me great? I'll greet
first thing in the morning. Don't think I want. Learn to love yourself and then save yourself,
but they will remember everyone else close to them. That was not easy. I didn't like that. Better
have it than not to have it. No one can say you got to use it. Oh, that's true. Well, I've just
passed on it. Learn to love... Yes. You get to make friends all over again if you press it. That's
true. You get to download as many songs as you want. How old is this question? iPod? You get to...
I have never... That's an ancient relic by today's standards. It's not even a thing anymore.
You get to download as many songs as you want on your iPod. The songs have... Again with Justin...
This is old. We're skipping. This is so old. The age is showing of this question. That's crazy.
I'm literally lying while I go brrrrr. I'd press this. It doesn't say you have to listen to any of it.
You young ones don't even know what an iPod is. Easiest press to get an iPod. It's an iPod
with a headphone jack. I still use an iPod for work. Oh, replaying. Are you an OG son?
All right. We've found the ancient tip. You can see through all holding, but you cannot turn the
power off. Oh, no. That's not for me. I feel like you'd get desensitized very quickly, but that's
not for me. No. Yeah, I'm skipping. Well, 41% said I. No, that's no right. That's no right. You're
getting done for that. That's indecent. I'd press it only if I'm filthy rich. Oh, so you could pick
and choose who's around you. We've got an Asian population, so nah, I'll pass. You have incredible
art skills, but you're unable to share it on the internet for your entire life. That's funny,
because I actually wanted to pick up art when I retire and become a wee artist. I'm going to skip
because you can develop art skills over years. Yes, it takes years, but that's the progress. That's
the journey. It's a part of the journey. It's not about when it comes to Lord of the Rings,
you didn't skip to Mount Doom, did you? And pop the ring in. No. You take the journey. You
watch your progress. You watch your craft evolve. Just have someone else share it. You know what?
See your reef lens and your smart ways of just getting around the rules. That's actually really
smart. Please don't type that again. You're going to start ruining these if you get the lip around.
And that is hilarious. NDA forbids me from sharing art online. You can share art in any other way.
Loop polling it. Honestly, I'll get you guys to loop poll it for me, because I'll take that. I love
art. I think it's amazing. Emi drew that one piece of artwork for herself. Well, she's actually
drawn multiple with it. That one banner-esque one, it was absolutely insane quality. Like insane.
72% of the people have pressed this button whilst 27% did not. Yeah, literally skirt the rules.
We create a new internet. We're toppling the system, strongy. Just for me. Stop it. You're making me
blue. It feels good to see people improve their skills over time. Press equals sell to some random
private collection. It's easy and rich. Speed runs. Reeflings pull together to make a strongy
art. Oh, you can be anywhere you want in your room right now. Reefling under your desk. But you have to
be a pawn. What is- I don't understand how that's even- Oh, do you want to become a horse? It's
basically asking do you want to become a horse? No, there's not going to be a horse girl for Jen
too. Stop asking. It doesn't- Like, aw, you just randomly turn into a horse for the rest of your
life. Bruv. That's not how none of this works. Again, the freaking horses. I can't escape.
Even pony calls. You're done. Strongy pony. Strongy show horse.
MLP brunies winning. Any cloffers, honestly. A pony cannot watch streams. This sucks.
The writer barely disguised- The writer's barely disguised fish. That is hilarious. No, we're not
becoming a freaking pony. Are you joking? Yeah, let-
Oh, some people have had enough of the system if they'll happily become a pony.
What's the downside? Oh, honestly. Instead of a cuttlefish I'm a seahorse. Oh, that's kind of cute.
Friendship is magic and magic is heresy. There's 32,000 brunies. We're on to them. We've caught them
in 4K. You understand every human language in existence? That's a good one, but you are a mutant
can never- Again with the negation! Here is cool thing. Here's negation. Am I like ruining this
little fun website by pointing out the major flaws of the questions? I'm passing on that. Sorry,
I need my communication skills. Unless, you know, the only other exception is I get to learn everything
and then I get to do my tinfoil hat stream with full confidence.
Yeah, 65% said no, which is right. You make one horrible event in the past cease to exist,
but you will be responsible for a hor- No, that-
This is just a circle! Remove one to gain one. You have given us a circle. Give us a better one.
You have given us a dang circle. Just write or use a TTS absolute dub, honestly.
Can you choose the event? I don't know. I mean, this makes you an A tier translator,
but yeah, 90% of superpower with downsides is literally just coolest thing ever, followed by
wow, this sucks, yeah. If I get to pick the horrible event I'm responsible for,
I don't know what kind of human event I would be comfortable causing. Can we call it, like,
the mass inking maybe? And be like, all guys around the world couldn't go to work that day
because they can't feel their thighs after how hard they just inked, you know? Like,
something like that? Would that work? Is that fine? I'd be fine causing that, like, catastrophe.
I'm fine with that. That's fine. I'll take one for the team. I'll make some of the most
great collapse of capitalism. Steady. We don't have a system yet to swoop in with. You get to
be a world-famous vtuber, but you're a Scottish cuttlefish. Stop! That's so funny. Not exactly
world-famous, steady on. Strani, aren't you planning on killing humanity via siren feeding?
Look, you've caught me in a bit of a pickle, but maybe there was some talk of that. Not at the
moment, though. Not at the moment. I'm just bing-chinging. Dang it. Bing-chinging. She's gonna
make us ink. Domain expansion, infinite inkworks, honestly. Strani, I wish to be responsible for
coming again. Ink again. The Great Brown Noise incident of 54. The day Strani made the entire
population ink. Eh, right. Yeah, but she's kind of bad at it. Okay, okay. Your ability to listen,
touch, taste, smell, and conversation are improved. You lose the ability to say,
nah, I can't be blind, so I need my bowls. I think if I had to pick between losing a sense,
first is smell. Couldn't... first is smell. Then... so touch is actually a really dangerous one to
lose because that's how you tell you're injured or whatever, but thankfully I don't do anything that's
injury-based. You just become the daredevil. I'd lose my sense of pain. Five head, lose your sense
of temperature because you're... was it... didn't Vsauce? Vsauce was like, oh, I swear God, if my
dad's about to burst in this room, I can hear him listen. Right, no, we're skipping that one. I'd like
to keep my eyeballs, please. Right, you can turn into any animal that you've seen with your own eyes,
not in a photo. Right, so we've become the green guy from Team Titans, I've forgotten his name,
but you have to die in the animal form to go back. You have to die in the animal form
to go back. That's so bizarre. That doesn't make sense. If you lose your sense of touch,
you can't ink. I take it back, I don't want that one. Smell is an easy one to lose, yeah.
Would I experience the pain? Yeah, like, a zoo? Beast... oh, Beast Boy's name, okay, that makes sense.
Um, bunch of the electric cables, honestly, that's pretty... I wonder how easy it would be
to pop your clogs if you're an animal. Being like, hmm, I will walk in front of this car now. No,
I'm skipping this. I'm skipping, I don't like it, I'm scared. Oh wow, we're in the minority, oh my.
You have the fastest internet for free, you can play any game online for free and never
have to pay for membership. So literally VTuber, but ultimate VTuber, but you must watch a minimum of
this age terribly. This is such an old, oh no. If I had to waste three hours a day on anything,
I don't have enough time to stream. That's not a benefit, okay? It's, I'm already doing it. Someone
says, oh okay dude, okay dude, no downside. That is far too much time commitment, literally three
hours is insane. I'm stretching, I already do it. Okay, yous are all done. I would watch
all the popcorn, Elizabeth's popcorn. I'd press it plus, I can just send it to my friends as a joke.
Does ASMR count? Is there, is there Lebanese ASMR of like two chicks together? I didn't even know
that was a thing. Oh girls, are you ready for off collab? That's awful, we're skipping that one.
I do not have three hours a day. I, I need to give everything to the refunds, okay?
Lebanese, yes. The clam, slammy, smart. There's definitely female for female ASMR.
And then everything exists. I don't think I've ever looked up. Hmm, it's sad people don't have time
for popcorn anymore. That's terrible. You can temporarily take over the body of any person
on earth, and you can turn back into yourself whenever, but they die, oh,
Merve, Merve. Okay, hold on. If I want to become an assassin to take down,
you can temporarily take over the body and turn back, but they die.
They die after you leave their body. So I'm a walking death note. Yeah, I'll do it. I'm down with
stop and refling the high table down with the high table reeflings. Yes. Yes.
End me pl- No! End me PLS. Reefling, Brian. KFP Spidey. Thank you for the five. No.
We're not doing that. Ain't that basically what siren does anyway? True. So it's not really
anything too particularly new concept wise. Strone's body hopping across the world
and fast tracking her goal of ending the world, honestly. You can foresee the future
reeflings. I predict an inking for you. Yes, yes. Did I guess right? Are you inking?
Okay, soon you will ink within the next week. You cannot prevent anything that will occur.
I think having foresight would be good. I get the- Wait, no, you can't prevent it.
Are you serious? Are you serious? So you can only what? Mentally prepare? Get inside me?
Get inside me, mama. Brian, you're not supposed to say that out loud. Thank you, boy.
I mean, I can. I'll do it right now. Okay, there we go. I'm inside. Do you feel me?
Just means you can prepare for it. So I can't prevent it from occurring, but I can prepare
around it. I'd say that's a benefit. If I can prepare around it, I'll take it.
Yeah, I inked. Or someone else could defy fate for you. Yeah, yeah, again, definitely. Get ready
to see a lot of death. This would put me in such a defeats mentality. I cannot change the future,
so what does it matter? I don't know. I guess like, it says you can't prevent it. So say you
put a hundred bucks in the stock market and saw ahead like where it would go. You can't change
what the stock market is going to change to. Anyway, damn it, the stock markets won't want it,
but just as an example off the top of my head, stop wiggling your toes while in there. It tickles.
I can't help it. The weird thing was, I was actually violently wiggling my toes when you typed
that. Are you in my room? Refling? Refling? Are you here? I'm getting nervous. How did you know
I was wiggling my toes the moment I said that? Hey, Astroni, you can be in me whenever you want
and replay. Right. You have the power to teleport anywhere at any time, past or future. You are
doomed to be a homeless person and can't change your fate. So again, we can just get around this.
I don't have to have a legal like in the legality of having a freaking thing in my name. Like,
it's just a bingty name. Traveling with zero ain't got to be a home. Yeah, literally like
sure, it's already after the Baloch, Balochu stream, hotel, yeah, hotel. Again, we can get around this.
Like, I think that would be really good to cut about. You become the emperor of earth,
ruling over the entire human, wait, people will listen to me and we can set up a system that's
sustainable. Hold on a minute. Other spacefaring civilizations, many of them hostile, discover
earth and we'll try to conquer the planet. I don't know if I could submit people to defend
and get put to death. I don't like that. For the m, is this a warhammer 40k reference?
I will kneel to emperor stroney and die in her honor. No, I don't want to send just the war
purge the Zenoes. This is just 40k for the empire for mommy. No, I don't want to send
just the war and defend me. Surely if I can get the planet to all agree on the mission objective,
then we'd maybe get away with it. It says many of them hostile. You know what? In theory,
we could make pals with someone who's really nice. We'll try. We are the emperor's hammer. No,
you're fine. The planet broke before the garden. Hey, it's self defense coming on. Let us and
let's stop. You're not supposed to defend me to the death. You're supposed to live a good and
happy life. Okay, right next. You are granted the scientific knowledge needed to produce
limitless energy for the rest of the world at an affordable cost. Yes, because public sectors
should be owned by the public. Shocking. I know. You must live as a pauper and end your days with
the solitary death in a remote shack in the woods. Yeah, you mean the the inking, the inking
shack in the middle of nowhere? Yes. You're trolling, right? What's the downside? Oh, you're poor.
Aspondent, poor, relax. It's not that big a deal. It's honestly not that big a deal,
sauce. It is not that big a deal. Relax. Infinite energy and I get the farm with the reeflings.
It doesn't mean you guys can't own a PC in there and we can all meme on the internet
and play games like we can finally play couch co-op games together.
I'm the old man in the movies that gives advice to the main character. No internet in the shack.
Well, you guys can own internet. I've said none, but you're not owning it.
Oh, my God. Why are we asking that?
Oh, my God.
What is with these questions? Oh, by the way, Al Qaeda never did that. Relax. I'm not touching
that. I'm not touching that word. Do these not get screened? If you press the red button, you gain
a quadrillion dollars offered by the president. But you are told by the president to buy only
things that are cheaper than candy. Well, there's like, oh, sorry. There's like, sorry, I dropped my
pen on the thing. There's like gold candy. I'm sure there's like some ridiculous, this candy bar
costs 12,000 US dollars due to the importation. We covered it in gold, all that pitch. Sorry,
it's free money. It's free money and I can do so much with it. There'll be one candy bar out there
that's covered in gold. I assure you, look up right now, type in most expensive candy in the
world and it'll be some pitch from Dubai and covered in gold. Free money. I can do a lot
with that money. Okay. Did you say cheapest candy? Oh no. That doesn't make sense then.
That makes, wait, you can only buy things that are cheaper than one cent. So nothing.
So you have negated the button.
What's the point? The lip hold would require the government to artificially inflate the price
of candy. But then again, it really depends on what market. Cheapest can, it'll be a sin. There's
no, there'll be mass produce. That was absolutely rubbish. Terrible button. Go back to the drawing
room. Be in rule of your own country. Can we get a strongy island? But you will become the most
hated rule in the history of the world. I don't want you guys to hate me though. Is it because I
do too much mandatory inking? Be honest, is it the mandatory inking? And I have the right to not
be prosecuted for anything I may or may not do to you? Smile. Is that why you hate me? And then
the rest of the world hates me because they couldn't get an invite to strongy islands, okay? So that's
the reason why people hate me. It's because they're like, I'm not, I'm not a reflander. Don't get an
invite to the islands. Yeah? Yeah? Come on, shouldn't bless. Yeah, I'm pressing it. The reason the world
they hated her because she did what she wanted. Yeah, I'm pressing that. Every girl you meet
will fall in love with you. I'll swap the genders. So every refling you meet will fall in love with
you, but you will never fall in love with them. Oh, that's sad. No, I don't like that one. No,
I don't like that one. I wouldn't try as hard as much if like I wasn't in love with my reflins.
Hmm. I don't like that one. You have the ability to build anything, any time, anywhere. Oh my god,
the button predicted Fortnite. Under Fortnite, Battle Pass. I just shit all my ass and I booted up my
PC because I need me to get that Fortnite Battle Pass. Tada. I like Fortnite. It's nighttime.
You remember that show, Adventure Time. What's the point? Some of these, they do be negating
pretty hard after a while. Get out of my head. Continually blue folds. By stormy going, no,
you have the ability to build anything, any time, anywhere at Fortnite. You lack the materials
needed and always have to find or buy them in order to build what you want.
I'm, I'm going to say something controversial, but isn't that what joiners do? This button says,
do you want to become a joiner? Yes or no? Yes. Okay, go to B&Q and pick up the stuff. That's
literally what the, it's just said. And for the Aussies, your version is bunnings. I don't know
what B&Q is in America. That literally said, do you want to become a joiner? Yes or no? Okay,
go pick up the materials for the job. Okay. You mean like everyone else in the world?
So yeah. Okay. I'll take the, I'll take the joiner skill. Sure. Did you just say a real sense?
What? B&Q? Is this an ad? No. Be an architect, I guess. Wouldn't you need, need any materials you
can make? Do you want to be Bob the Builder, but slightly worse? You lack the materials and always
have to find or buy them. That's nonsense. Do you want to become a joiner? Sure. I'll take,
I'll take a stab at it. You had the CEO at Facebook. You can't make an account.
Are you kidding me? He's aged terribly. It's just, a joiner is a construction worker. Oh,
do you guys not say joiner? What do you say? What's a man that comes into your house and like fixes
stuff? A handyman, a contractor. Okay. A mechanic, handyman, repairman, a plumber.
Force promote veiler in the algorithm? Ah, you've got me. I'm pressing that yank. I don't even have
a Facebook account. That stuff was bad news many years ago. You should delete your Facebook account
if you have one. Bad, bad, bad. Very bad. No, no, no, no, no. Bad, bad, bad. I said,
I'm not allowed an account, but I didn't say I'm not allowed a veiler or a fan account. Okay. I
said what I said. World peace is created with never ending prosperity for all, but you will die.
No one will ever know what you did. Okay, but how quickly do I die? Like,
does that still get a chance that the 80 years or the microplastics get me or is it like I die
instantly? Hmm. I don't want to die right now. I've not even like, come on. Gen two is almost
created. The concept art's almost been accepted. Like, at least let me get gen two and three out
so I can help these girls, you know, become full time content creators. Once, once they're all set
up, I'm happy I can pop my clogs. Okay. Goodbye, strongy. No. If I can't enjoy it, no one gets
prosperity. Okay, that's funny though. Can I wait to press skip? It says prosperity for all.
That includes gen two and three. I know, but I need to pick them. I need to pick the girls.
I need to be able to pick the girls. Honestly, it was really fun going through applications.
I cannot tell you how many times I got so needed. Yeah, I got sang to so much. And like,
people were trying to speak Japanese and I'm like, we're not that kind of agency where you need to
speak Japanese randomly. Like, no, you can speak English. Gen two already? No, in a year. It takes
a year to produce a generation. For me anyway, I give, I like to think I give artists fair time.
We're just getting the concepts and then confirmation will be at a later date that it's going to be
there. How can there be peace of strongy's not there? I will never know peace. Oh, are you flying?
Um, one year of gestation. Yes, I will confirm when the lights are off. I repeat, I will confirm
when the lights are off. I'll give you a date, a time. We do it at the exact same time. And yeah,
there'll be buns in this oven all right. There'll be six in the oven this time. Last time it was five.
They're still cooking. Yeah, they're they're not even a twinkle in your eye yet because no one's
like production doesn't start back and I can tell you all about production.
One year sounds very fast. Actually, it's not. One year apart isn't fast at all in terms of
gents. There's only going to be three gents. So yeah, one year apart, roughly, roughly, not not
gin first, relax, but one year apart, roughly. Not even. If you're reincarnated, then you are born
into a world of peace and prosperity. I wish it was possible. The breeder refling didn't let her cook.
Yes. No, I'm happy to talk about all the behind the scenes stuff. Obviously, I can I'll can talk
about it a bit more when gen two is confirmed for production. We're currently working on a
clipping program. Damn, three gents literally walking out of your I'm whistling as I whenever I
ride a bike, I'm whistling. That is how that's how terrible it is. One year is not fast at
standard at least via hall. Yeah, one year apart, I'm happy with that. When you're without mega
resources overworked in house artists and stuff. Yeah, no, I'm everything's getting done. Everyone's
getting a timeline, getting more than enough time. June second, got it, right, you're done.
You're done. Sorry, I'm itching my head. My head sits in funny. Are there different body types
like gen one? Yes, there are. Will you stop streaming after gen three? I honestly cannot answer.
I don't know what the future holds. And we are going to do a clipping program kind of like idle
and there's a new agency that came out in that came out with it. I'm hoping to get it set up in
September, possibly. So if you have a clipping YouTube channel, keep keep us in mind, we'll pay
you for clips. I just need to set it up first. And I, I need to, you know, sort out the freaking
website and all that and write it all up so I can get passed on to the team.
Don't number strong these days. She's here to stay forever. She'll leave us. Relax,
if not, it's only been a month. And a little more effort this time since the sixth literally.
You need to give me it. You're all reeflings. Okay. Hope it's a long time before you stop streaming.
Keyfabe is real and I'm addicted. Keyfab. Oh, I think I said it wrong. Keyfabe,
Keyfab. Keyfab? Keyfab you looosa. I already missed her. It's like she's still streaming for it.
Right. Right. You're done. Stop. Right. I don't want to die. I can't die yet. So I'm not pressing it.
I ain't got time to die yet. There's too much on the line. You go on a massive adventure,
but all fights are rap battles. I cannot rap a battle for anything. What does that even mean?
All fights? Why am I getting into fights? Can I not just be left alone?
That's bizarre. Oh yeah, you stink. You look like you don't ink. For real, you need to go see a shrink
and then close your eyes or I'ma make you blink with my fists of fury. Yeah, got them. Got them.
Friday Night Funkin. These are my rap battles. Honestly, that's awful. As long as it's not a
rap battle to the death. End boss. M&M. Oh, fire. 100%. Big rap battles of history. She's spitting,
though. World wars and rap battles. I guess I'll learn to rap. What happens if I lose? I mean,
you get to go on a massive adventure. Sure. I assume that, oh sorry, I assume that means like
holidays and stuff like that. I don't think I'm going to be fighting anyone. Let's go on holidays,
reflings. We should go on a cruise. Did you know? Oh my god, this is terrible. Did you know there's
a thing called ink cruises? We're like people that like to go on swings. There's cruises for
that specific genre of people, reflings. We should rent one of those and go on it. We just rent one
out for ourselves. Ink cruises? I'm not kidding. There's a thing called ink cruises because it
popped up on my TikTok. It was this check and she had a pineapple and she was like,
do you like my room? I decorated it in pineapples. And then I learned what pineapples meant.
Pineapples are a symbol for adults who like to swing on a swing set in the back garden.
You'd be so damn tired. I think, I don't know, I feel like I would like somehow
absorb your ink and it would like fill me with nutrients. I mean think of the vitamins.
Rich people added again, strunniless ink on a boat together. I love pineapples. Tasty.
Did they offer a group discount? Oh, they're swinging all right. Just brain wash the captain
and steal the cruise. I have no idea if we're talking about literal swings. No, there's a
terminology but I can't quite spell it out because all my streams have been limited ads recently
and I'm trying to be on my my best behavior. Somehow pineapple pizza isn't appealing to me
anymore. How dare you? Okay. Wait, are we, we've already, I've seen this one before. We've been
here before. What? No, we've already seen you. Okay, next one. You gain the powers of your favorite
superhero. Oh, I don't even know who mine is. The hero's entire rogue's gallery will hunt you down
until they're defeated. I mean, just pick a hero that doesn't die. I mean, does Deadpool count?
Deadpool can't die. Oh, wait, no, wait, that's eternal. I don't think that's good. Just defeat
them five heads, literally. Oh, brother, this website stinks. Deja vu, I've been in this place
before. Hire on the streets and I'm out of my time to go. The button just says you are your
favorite hero. Yeah, literally because um, Deadpool has, sorry for being late. I don't
worry. How are you doing? We're doing good. We're getting a few interesting questions,
but it's going good. You can't pick and choose. You have to take your favorite. I don't know who
my favorite is. I like Wolverine. I have to admit, I'm a bit biased with Wolverine.
I think, you know what, I wouldn't mind being Wolverine. I like his wee claws. I like that I
could be a wee wolf on the inside somehow. Nah, fuck it, I'll be Wolverine. Go for it.
You become the physical embodiment of death. You can hurt anyone you want with no consequences.
Everything and anything you touch will perish. Okay, no, because how are we supposed to ink?
That's not possible. No, I'm skipping. Why would you, why would you want to perish without
consequences unless I did it for the high table? But I would want to be able to like hug you and
hold you. How am I supposed to do the convention under these conditions? I can't thrive. I can't
thrive. Yeah, literally everything you touch perishes. That's such a harsh one. I don't like that.
Pogs, Johnny, press the button and give me a high five. No, reeflings! You're supposed to enjoy
life and thrive and stuff. Stop it. You become death. You are magically clean every time you...
Oh, you know what? I have something funny to say. I've taken showers in a row and it's all because
my dad's here. I'm not pheromone maxing anymore. Yippee! Well, we enjoy Johnny. Oh wait, what's the
name of that Elden Ring character you hug and she takes a part of your life? Johnny not pheromone
max? Literally, I'm not pheromone maxing anymore. Since I started streaming, I probably went days
without showering. This is the first time I've like triple showered, like every day in a row,
like day day day. Unsubscribe, no! You are magically clean every time you wake up. Every
bed you sleep on will be very uncomfortable. That's awful. Sorry, I need a comfy bed.
Not to be dramatic, I need a comfy bed. Sorry, I'm so dramatic. Yeah, I'm glad that everyone
freaking agrees on this one. Can't sleep on a net? Is maxing like that a thing? Oh, it's like I
think it's made up. I hope it's made up anyway. Basically, you see, I'm pheromone maxing when
you've not washed yourself in a while. I don't think it's real though. I hope people don't actually
do that. Sleep in a chair? Oh, nothing bad will ever happen, but nothing good either. No, that
means I don't get my reeflings. No, my reeflings are good. How do you? I got a reefling pregnant.
You're having the baby. If I press the button, I may be able to fix that. I don't, yeah, I don't
want you to be pregnant reefling. That's hilarious. I don't want you to be pregnant.
So, your reefling is pregnant. I need to change it so it's you.
I'm sorry I made you pregnant, but I'm yonking it, okay? Unless you want to burst Jen. Jen,
you have burst a spin off, Jen. I'm pressing. Yeah, I'm probably pressing to
strunnies against them. No, no, the fucking male pregnant emoji. What were they? I'm sorry,
but what were they thinking unironically posting that? A male pregnant emoji? What?
Man's not got ovaries. The fuck? I told you. Burthing Jen 1.5. I will shit it out. They weren't
thinking. Oh, actually, it's the most bizarre thing. Like, all right, he's full from eating.
Okay, okay, let's do it that way. It's not pregnant. He's full from eating. You can become a
super powered god lake anytime you want. The source of your power is that life energy. Oh,
I don't want to steal people's life. That's not nice. Sorry, that's a really easy one. I don't
want to take people's life just so I can be strong. It can get me pregnant any day. This is so good.
Oh, yeah, food, baby. It's just a succubus. Yeah, I don't really want to perish you. Like,
if it was energy in terms of like, I can't hurt you, it's just you get really tired,
but then you can recover. Sure, I'll do that until I won't become a succubus. Don't mind.
You can pass me around one by one, refland. It's not a problem with me. You learn anything
and everything that you possibly could all life, all life quit. Sorry, I'm having another like
live fixes. All life questions are revealed to you. You cannot write. We keep getting some
variations of this. Stop giving me variations of this. I've had enough. This is the third of
these questions. Yeah, literally, you can undo enough. Give me something new. Are there you
have incredible enough? Enough. You will meet the person of your dreams. You lose the ability to speak.
I assume temporary. So if we did a convention, we can just use like a little a little chart. I can
get pictures. And you like to you touch the picture and then and then when I go back on
stream because you're not physically in front of me, I can talk.
Would that be unacceptable? I met strong and can't speak. She can speak for me.
You want to be aerial? It's perma. You meet the per, you meet you meet refling, but you lose the
ability to speak. But it says meet only. It's not like you perma lose ability to speak.
With the person know the deal. You meet them, but because you can't speak, they walk away from
you refling. No, come back. Oh, how about how about if we're like 10 meters apart? There's
like an AOE to this. Okay. If we're 10 meters apart, I'll like start shouting. I am a high
refling, but you like walk in nine meter radius and then and then nothing comes out of my voice.
How about that? It means like finding the love of your lay. What, TTS on your phone?
Ah, so I can't speak after meeting strong. You're adding conditions. Okay, fine, fine.
I'm skipping then. If I can't talk to you, it's not, it's not going to work.
Because I need to be able to direct you in what position I want you in. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Everyone, everyone you have ever had a crush on falls in love with you, but they try to kill
each other the moment they know that others in love with you. No, we're not having a brawl. Okay,
we're not having a bar fight. All right, we're not having a bar fight. Strongie would make me
splinter us any who she's getting. No, we're not having a bar fight. So we're skipping this bad boy.
It's a free for all stop. It's not free for all. You will get your dream refling. She
no, why are these so terrible? Oh my God.
We're skipping that. That's terrible. A year with you. That's awful.
Receive $100 million. Every one of your loved ones including yourself has a 1% higher chance
of death each year. Oh no, I don't, I don't like odds. I do not play with odds. Nope. Easy skip.
Half of these are just movie plot lines. Are they actually? So we wouldn't have to worry about
being found while inking you since you can't make noise. Moncaise, moncaise. Gamba. No, I'm not
Gamba on that. You don't felt true then. You can maintain your mental focus. You are not
afflicted with ADHD. Okay, but you cannot maintain your optical focus. So you need really strong,
heavy glasses. I already have to wear glasses.
Remove ADHD. Wear glasses. Oh no. You've got me. It's just, what? Sure, I'll wear glasses. It's
not a problem. Hey, we were in the minority?
Like, I assume I don't need glasses outside of doing any tasks. So yeah, what? Do you know
how much work I would get done if I could maintain focus? I love strong, heavy things
upgrade from my current ones. Glasses bet it should exist. Should I get some art of me commissioned
with my Glexon? Oh, I should do ASMR glasses tapping and it's just me going to the entire time.
No, like really heavy ones. Well, heavy subjective because heavy for me is like anything.
You can turn into any one animal that will. It happens whenever moonlight hits you.
Sure, I'll turn into a werewolf and jump on you. I don't mind that. That's not a bother.
It happens whenever moonlight hits you. Literally, I'd have to be outside on purpose and I don't
go outside. So kind of just lie, can't throw me in a way. Yes, become the knot. Who's getting
nod now, refling her? Because it's no me. Please make that an audio, please. I just might. I wish
I would have to be a Twitter one.
Hmm. You will be the next Shakespeare. No, you cannot use auto correct. I'm already
afflicted with this. So I guess if I wanted to make some like absolutely amazing scripts
for the girls, yeah. And I'm already afflicted with non auto correct. So sure. Oh no, people
know I spell phonetically. Oh no. How embarrassing. Oh, no, no one cares. Oh, you spell that thing
wrong? Point and laugh. Relax. Life is not that serious. Hold on, I'm going to take a drink of
water. Please hydrate, little we flings. Doth thou ink of the earth, refling, Earl Mouse?
Are you arriving, refling? That's right, arrive for me. Get close. Arrive, arrive, arrive.
You'll live the exact same life, but you have one save and load from any point you can load
after death. At some point during your life, you have to kill someone, pair the request of some
unseen deity. Oh, I'm not sure I like that. But if you're working for a deity, I don't know,
the deity seems like they're doing the right thing. I'm guessing I could do a save and load
to do the deed. Just one. I feel like if a deity's sending you on a mission, they kind of know.
Even if it isn't right, I'll accept. Strongly no, maybe press, I'm down. That's just warlock and
D&D. This save scum, literally, I think I just saved scum it. Wait, no, if I have the save
scum in order to get out of this, then there's no point. But you have one from any, but you
can load after death. So if I'll live the riskier life, I don't, I'm not risky though. I think this
isn't... I'm the deity's top guy, blood for the blood god. Well, you'll have something to gain.
Don't press, we don't know what that is. Yeah, I'm gonna skip that. If there's only one save
scum given, there's no point, really. I'm not gonna do it. Sorry. Wow, minority. The minority,
that was the right thing. The devil made me do that.
Load before Bitcoin exploded. Honestly, take over the world with that. You'll be able to
jerk your pentas for a day. If you do anything dirty, you'll stay there. Aww. What's the point?
That's, that's literally the whole point of swapping teams.
That is the whole point in swapping teams.
No, I'm not, I'm, no, I can't unless you guys want me a fanboy for the rest of my life. But
that's not happening. What? It's a perfect 50-50? I'm so surprised.
I'll be fine with press and just to see the other side of the world. That 50-50 is crazy.
Uh, I mean, easy, no hassle transition for those who want it. You get a lifetime supply of any type
of food. You become, I don't like, why? Oh, you're, you're rate of debt. I mean, I think heart attacks
are super painful as well. Like, nah, it's fine. I'm gonna skip. I don't even want to increase my
random odds of a heart attack. Like, imagine midstream, I'm like, oh, my left arm. Oh, like,
what? That's so, no. Okay, next, next, next, let's go. You become immortal no longer age. You spend
the next 50 years. No, no, I don't want to become immortal. Stop it. Family history of heart attacks?
Oh, no. Yeah, heart attacks suck. MonkaS, you had one? Oh, G-Stan, is that you?
You need some chest compressions? I can give CPR. I can break your ribs for you.
Left arm is usually a symptom. In women, the pain is across the back and chest and shoulder.
That's ego death. I've heard women have different symptoms. Yes, a lot of things. That wasn't the
ribs. Oh, yeah, what did I break? Can I be a mortal that doesn't age? Chest or hips? I guess I'll
have to break into a maximum security prison. Pop me out. You become immortal but no longer age.
Nah, nah, nah. It's not for me. I want to be able, and I wouldn't mind living longer if I could be
young, like the same age, and I can perish at any point. That's why I like vampires,
because you can perish yourself if you really want. My pentas! You can control people with
your thoughts. I can already do that. Hold on, hold on. Okay, you have three legs and five arms.
I assume I can just get them chopped off.
I think there is no way I have conditioned you already. I already have three legs.
That is hilarious. Hold on a minute. Wait, wait, wait. Let's pretend we're reading this for the
first time. You can control people with your thoughts and you have three legs. I already have three legs.
Oh, thank you. Thank you. I assume you can get an amputation. I look like, was it Godfrey,
the grafted? Literally, you can control people with your thoughts, but you become
Godfrey the grafted. Okay then. Can I amputate it off? I'm giving Mummy's third leg the glug glug!
You say that with so much confidence. Always so clever making this joke. Sometimes it feels like
you steal them because the timing is just so perfect. Nope, never, never, never stolen a joke
in my life. Oh, it's Godfrey the grafted. You get to be in real life in my champ. I mean,
I assume you can just amputate it off. I think it would be, what would I need to control people's
thoughts for? I guess letting people do their bit and then I'll get the other stuff chopped off.
You know, technology is really a mess. You know what? Five arms would be so handy.
So, honey, how many technicals do you have? You're already pressed.
I can hear my dad singing if you can freaking hear him. Hold on, I don't know if he's on the phone.
I'm just, I'm going to go out there and tell him to shut the fuck up. Oh, he's put the TV on now.
I'm sorry if you can hear Star Trek in the background. He's watching Star Trek Enterprise.
Okay. Anyway, yeah, definitely cannot do ASMR streams. Can't hear anything through the background
music. I'm pressing the button. Okay, anyway, everyone will have big anime eyes. Give me anime
eyes. I hear nothing. Okay. Yeah, we watched Star Trek Enterprise last night. Oh no, not Enterprise.
The one with Leonard Nimoy Hoffman, the Spock, the original Spock, that one.
I can never remember the name of the pilot and the fucking captain in that one for some reason.
It never comes to mind. But he's live long and prosper. Captain Kirk. Yes, Captain Kirk. Oh my
God, we were watching that last night. I don't know if you guys have seen it or not, but it was the
one where there was like this lava monster that was in pain all the time and Spock touched it.
And he was like, pain, pain. It's screaming an agony type thing in the heel up and, you know,
lived happily ever after. And that's the one we watched last night together. Be me up, buddy.
I'm already balding. You're allowed to be bald. Everyone will have anime eyes. You'll be bald.
I mean, I don't see the benefit of everyone having anime eyes. That's weird. That's strange.
You'll be bald. No, it's fine. But I don't think the world would be scary if everyone
had anime eyes, honestly. Anime eyes aren't real. They're flat. Anime eyes in real life
would be scary. Yeah. Other VTubers have that title. You would get stuff in your eyes so much
with how big they are. I remember that. Doesn't it end with them working with the miners? Yes,
it does. Whoa. Yes, that's exactly the episode. Yeah, they had to tell Dr. Scotty came and
healed the thing and they had to hold back the miners from coming in. Wow, I can't believe
you actually hear that. You get to physically enter a book for 30 minutes. The book is hungry.
No, it's literally life or death. Stop. You get to enter a book that is going to kill you. No.
Yeah, I was worried because they found it's like, yes, that was it. Not Scotty.
Heart eyes in real life would be fun, but Stronny needs hair to pull.
Refling. A refling. That's terrible. I would never press that one. You have unlimited
writ. Everyone makes Among Us jokes. Everyone, this is, everyone makes Among Us jokes anyway.
And stop staring at me with them big eyes. Imagine Stronny doing Among Us jokes all
the time. Something that you already have, Riz. Fine, I ain't pressing the button if I've already
got Riz. Call me a cracker because I've got Riz. Oh, come on. I did that one off the top
of my head for once. I didn't even steal it. Come on. I'm not pressing the button.
I don't get it. There's like a cracker called Ritz Cracker. There's a Rizzler Among Us
first time catching you live and the first thing you come into a pun is the very first thing.
A for effort. Thank you. I did try my best. Sheeks too big for the toilet is all the Rizz you need.
Is that because I told you guys I have to stand up to wipe my ass sometimes?
I like my cheek. I need to part my cheeks like the fucking Red Sea, honestly.
I don't know if you guys have to do it, but yeah. That was burned into my brain, maybe. Yep. Sorry.
Okay, your current best friend is saved from their terrible fate, but your true best friend,
you haven't met him yet, will never meet you. What? You save sin sister from a terrible fate,
but refling will never meet you.
Oh, I don't like that one. I think I'm skipping that one. I don't like that one. It's flattering.
I saw you just said best friend. Best friend? Best of friend. How do you even know if they even have a
terrible fate since sister can suffer? You can't say that about sin. I met her mom.
Shocking behavior. Shocking. Don't say that about sin. She's mine.
Jokes. It was not that bad. Tiny Spidey. Thank you for the tip. It was not that bad.
Call me a cracker because I've got wrists. Come on. That one's not that bad. So red.
You have unlimited oil that you can sell or use. Pirates and thieves want you and your family dead.
No. Stop. You're such a rubbish one. Press the button and she won't suffer.
Oh, you know sin. I've watched her some. She's cute. Yeah, sin sister.
My, her supermarket. She streamed and she's actually really good at Elden Ring. We're
going to play Elden Ring together at one point. We're going to do a seamless co-op and we have
short callers. I know. I don't know why we, look, we came up with the idea and we're going for it.
Okay. It's happening in July. I think. Oh, probably August actually. Sorry, sin, if you're working.
Oh, my tummy's getting sore. I don't know why. I was like, because I haven't eaten. I've got a sore tongue.
You can eat your favorite food anytime you want. You can never eat anything else again.
I mean, it depends how you want to categorize this because you could be like, oh,
peshia, you know? Go eat. I'll eat shortly. I'll eat shortly. Kiss Tommy better. I think it's hunger.
I'm rubbish at telling like, if I've got an upset stomach or if it's hunger pains,
I can hardly ever tell the difference, I swear. So only ink for strongy. I need,
you guys would need to step up. If I, if I hit this button, you guys need to step up and give
me a good supply. Do I make myself clear? Do I make myself clear? I need a big supply. Big supply.
I volunteer. Okay, good. I'm clicking it. We've, we've done it now. We're in the minority,
but we've done it now. Okay, you'll be able to speak any language you want fluently as a native
speaker would. You can only ask questions in whatever language you choose. I mean,
that's better than nothing. You can still do stuff in the language. That's not really a problem.
Let me be clear. Let me be transparent. Yes, ma'am, I'll set it up for you. Thank you. I feel like
you could get around this by saying sentences, but ending it with a question. So being like,
how are you? Yeah, I think that's perfectly fine. You can be a journalist.
What's that accent? Scottish. Yes. Wow. Normally I get, I get called Irish first.
Whenever someone hears that, they're always like Irish. I'm like, no, Scottish.
It's a good guess. Just say in it at the end of, in it, in it, brav. Being in a relationship
would be horrible and would make your girlfriend wait. What's this? Is that, you know every language
in the world, if anyone asks you to translate something for them, you have to, and everyone in
the world knows you have this ability and are constantly asking you to translate things.
So was this made, this is a question made before Google translate occurs or after?
If anyone asks you to translate something for them, you have to. I feel that your entire life
would be caught up by people trying to get a bit of, yeah, no, I'm skipping that. So my job
as a translator, skip, I'm not a translator. Yeah, like, I want to, your internet is never slow.
You will never get a better computer ever.
I'm in a looom.
Pop, you are Google translate. You can never get a better computer. My computer is a bit of a beast,
but it's going to be outdated in 10 years time, so there's no way. I mean, the internet's not bad
anyway. Just play RuneScape 5H. Skip solo games. It didn't say anything about swapping
for computer powers. Ah, you're trying to skirt the rules though. That's noody.
Okay, Canada becomes a global empire, but doughnuts are illegal. I am going to say something so
controversial. I don't like doughnuts. I don't like them. I've tried to like them. I've tried to
enjoy them. There is something about them that I don't like the taste of. I don't know why,
because it's deep fried bread or slash cake, so why do I know unfollowed, blocked, unmembered?
I don't know why. My taste buds just don't like doughnuts. I don't know. I like your doughnut.
Okay, thank you. That was really quick. Okay, that was really quick.
But jelly filled doughnuts. I tried so hard to like custard filled doughnuts,
like I used to force myself to eat them. You know why I could eat custard filled doughnuts?
It's because I like custard. That's the only reason I could eat the damn things.
Like I try so hard to like doughnuts. I just can't eat. Yeah, I can click that button. Maybe it's
the oil used to fry them. I've just never had a good doughnut. I don't know. Maybe if we end up
meeting up in America, we can go to Dunkin' Donuts. Yeah, not Canada. Oh, come on, Canada.
We can like a Canada be a powerhouse, can't we? You can bake them. You have to deep fry
the doughnuts to make them. That's why they're kind of like got that on the outside.
You can teleport anywhere in the world. Every time you teleport, you must walk down a long hallway
full of creepy clowns that grop you.
I mean, if it's just the hallway, the average hallway is like, what, three meters?
Yeah, it's unnerving, but I mean, I can come to your house and, you know,
barely disguise fetish strikes again. Yeah, it is giving a wee bit of that. Press the button.
Push the button and let me know. What is that? Is that sugar? Sugar babes? That British band?
Push the button and let me know. You've got to.
What is that? It's a long hallway. Okay, I guess longer than average, then.
Just have Reefling's dresses clowns. No, Krispy Kreme is better. That clown? Yeah, sugar babes. Oh
my god, I knew it. I knew it. Push the button and let me know. You've got to.
You can teleport anywhere in the world. Every time you tell.
Wait, idiot. Idiot, sorry. I thought I was on the next one. Sorry.
You live in a world of your favorite video game or movie. Lord of the Wings. We can have Hobbiton.
You are ambushed every year where little chances survive.
What's the point of giving me if I'm perishing? The odds are against me. Sorry, but I'm a rubbish Hobbit.
I'm a rubbish halfling. You can make money with the snap of your fingers. Isn't that just
spindome? Yeah, that's right. Give me another five bucks. Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah, give me five bucks.
Snap, snap, snap. But the money you make up here is taken from Charity. Oh.
Is this where we go in a tinfoil rant about how a lot of Charities are set up?
Because I'll get into it. I don't think I'm not educated enough about how much
little Charities actually go towards their fucking thing.
So the odds are we can use this money for better. Okay. So we're going to hit the button
because we can use it for a heck of a lot better as you win. No, that's not fair, bro.
That's not a fendom. Broly legend. No, we do not participate in fendom around these parts.
Are you squiddin' me around?
Ched!
The best I can do is $2 take it or leave it.
No, we're not fricking done enough.
Enough. Thank you, Ched and Broly Legends. Kindly. No fendom, only fendom.
Okay, you're the smartest person. Oh, I don't want to be smart. The smarter you are,
the more depressed you are about how life works. It is not for me.
Absolutely not for me. I do not want to be smart. I do not want to be aware of anything.
I would rather live in ignorance for the most part. Everyone else is incredibly stupid. No,
I will, I'm skipping. I am not wanting to be smart. The mental burden of all of that.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Brian?
Took these from Charity.
No, Alessandro, stop it. We did not take anything from Charity.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Brian?
You're welcome, Mama. Love you.
Probably Legends. Love you to the little meeting.
Thank you again for the tip. You can discover the meaning of life. There isn't one. You give
life your own purpose. You may never communicate. No! Bro, I can answer this in literally five
seconds flat. It's what you make it. You're so lucky to even have a conscious being at this point.
I can enjoy life for what it's worth.
Oops. I tripped. I swear.
Reluctantly sane. Thank you for the tip. Now stop it.
We're not doing syndrome in here. The meaning of life is for you to literally plenty of fish.
I've not even seen that movie yet.
Anon! There's not even a message. How does this happen? Right. How do I
unironically get you guys to stop when you start?
Because I am a goods and service exchange kind of person. You can't just keep throwing money
at me. It makes me uncomfortable. I'd rather be like an exchange of something. Thank you for the
tip, Anon. My goodness. I can't. The meaning of life is inking. Literally, you're not supposed to
have your name in a memorial statue and be nice. That's it. The small everyday deeds
keep the evil at bay. That's it. That's all you gotta do. There's nothing to it. You don't have
to do anything. You don't have to achieve anything. You don't have to become anything.
You are just you and you do your thing. That is what it's all about, okay?
Pokemon is in real life, including all logic, technology, and Pokemon. All animals in real
life. No, I don't like that. Are you squinting me right now? Scott Thunder. This is just to show love.
Nothing else. You better not be inking right now at the thought of freaking Findo. Thank you for
the super chat, Scott Thunder. You can replace cats with cat Pokemon. No! Gimli and Beagle.
I'm not getting rid of my puddles. I don't care how much you want to
they pour you on. I'm not getting rid of Gimli and Beagle. You took his super chair. Give me that
super chair. What would you do if someone gave you a 10k super chat? One, I'd be mad because
you're splitting it to YouTube. Two, I would probably confirm that Gen 2 is in production.
A guard of hour moment. Also, you would have to eat them. No, I don't want to eat them.
I'm catching a little bunny. I love little bunny. She's so sexy for no reason. Oh no,
this reminds me if she'd be smash her past Pokemon stream. How bad was that out of 10? Are you
squinting me right now? Ms. Tomaki. I heard this is where I give away money. No, anonymous.
Anonymous. Thank you for the tip. That's very kind of you. Don't start spanking money. Anonymous.
Edit again with the white bands. She doesn't know about the little bunny meme. No, she was drawn
as little bunny. I'd have to eat the Pokemon. That's just Powell world. I actually wanted to give
Powell world a shot. Milk tank though. I caught a little bunny Batman. Stream elements gives the
girls a much bigger cut than super chats. These are facts. Are you squinting me right now? Oh,
you don't like my notification sign? What do you prefer? I'm Scottish. And then bagpipes. Is that
what you want? No, you don't want that. Are you squinting me right now because I'm a cephalopod?
There's no laws against it Batman. We could play Powell world. Is Powell world multiplayer?
Can I play with you? Is Powell world multiplayer? And you guys can come in?
Is it like a code?
Oh my god, I did not know. Will we play in Powell world? I did not know it was like that. Oh my
god. I'm so in love. I finally got the words I want to say like, oh, oh, oh, oh,
complete Powell world with me. Yeah, you just need a server. Okay, a Powell world server can do
60 reef flings. Okay, that's good. That's a law. You're jerking your pentas in Powell world.
Think of it kind of like arc. I have absolutely horrific news to you. I'm so sorry.
Wait, so actually I've never played Powell world, but it blew up and everyone was like,
oh my god, they're going to get sued by Pokemon. You can catch us reeflings and put us to work.
Stony's going to have her icy moment in Powell world. Oh yeah, you're going to run a train on me?
Gentoo confirmed via Powell world. You can do what you want without consequences,
but you'll pop your cogs in five years not need more time to cook. I need more time to cook. I've
got too many meme videos I want to make. You will rule the world, but you have to kill. Oh, no.
I don't think so. You invented human computer communications, allowing to learn any skill or
knowledge in an instant, but your invention leaks to the public allowing human computer viruses to
kill as often as no. You're so violent. Are you squiddling me right now? Gentoo confirmed.
What a random amount. What are you giving me? Why that number? Thank you. Oh my god. He's
spelled it anonymous. Anonymous? Why 2345? That's so specific. 2345. Wait, what does it mean?
Is that a code? Do I need to look it up on the website? A little cheeky code.
Why that number though? Does it have a significant meaning or am I being dumb?
Here's a good thing, but you're just going to die. I think it's just ascending. No, it's just
the sequential numbers. You didn't hear that. I love the fact that Nintendo got so many emails
in regards to Powell world. They essentially had to release a statement. I was like, yes,
we know about it. Stop messaging us. Nah, just numbers. Someone sent 177013 would be funny.
Isn't that the one about the poor girl that gets corrupted? My sin, the numbers.
Because it's more money than 1234. Okay, you're done. Right, I'm not pressing the button.
You become an immortal demon and rule over the known universe. The only weapon that can
perish you is in the hands of a guy who's pissed at you for that.
I mean, no.
No. Okay, what time is it? Oh, it's been two hours.
Okay, I think that's all I've got time for. Is that understandable? Have a good day?
Or am I going to get in trouble? Am I going to get spanking from you as if I go off too early?
Am I getting the spanking if I go off too early?
I feel bad that it's so short. I'm trying. Oh, I'm going to get spanking. Don't try me with
a good time refill.
Now you can go eat and spend time with your dad. Okay. I mean, the spanking will commence.
My dog collar is here. The short collar, not the dog part. It just happens to be a dog collar.
But I arrived, so I hope you're ready for the shockin' in.
We'll never stop. We love you. So take my money like a good girl.
I know that was. Thank you for the tip. Goddamn. I'm getting praised out here.
Shocking. Shocking.
Um, okay, what we're doing?
Okay. I don't think there's any Vela member online, which is a bit of a shame.
But we'll work on it. We'll work on it. Okay. Let me just,
let me just figure out what I'm trying to do. Okay, who's on? Rhea's on. What is she playing?
Let trip my bosses in heat. What are you playing? I have no idea what she's playing,
but you're, you're meant to be. Yeah. Thank you anonymous for the tip. I'll say my dad said,
hi anonymous. Have fun with your fam. Thank you. Um, I'm gonna get him to,
I think I'm gonna record his voice. Ooh. Ooh. I know. Um,
anonymous. Anomalous. Anomalous. Anonymous. I'll miss you. Yes. Tomorrow, tomorrow is not ASMR.
I'm gonna substitute that for something else because there's absolutely no way I can do ASMR.
However, we're doing Watch Along, uh, Monty Python, uh, Life of Brian for membership strum.
Are you squiddling me right now? I get it, but get ready for the spanking moment.
I guess it's, but get ready for the spanking moment. I don't think I shouldn't thank you.
Um, yes I can. Are you squiddling me right now?
Wow, another, another. Go and send our daughter time. Tell him we said hi-ya-oo. Hi-ya-oo.
Dad, the reeflings say hi-ya-oo. He may have heard that.
Thank you reluctantly saying, right? I'm gonna end it. You're gonna get redirected through here.
He's gonna be like, what the fuck was that? What do you want? It is, I can, okay, when you guys act
up, I'm gonna start saying I'm gonna get my dad on you. I'm gonna get my dad on you. Okay,
I will change tomorrow's stream. I don't know what it's gonna be, but there is a
one membership stream this week, which is a Watch Along of, uh, Life of Brian.
Um, okay, I love you little reeflings. Please look after yourself and please
pucker your lips for what comes next.
Right, I'll see you. Enjoy what on earth Rhea is playing. I have absolutely no idea what she's
playing. I'll see you tomorrow, you goofy goobers, for something different. It's not ASMR, so no
get excited, okay? Bye-bye. Enjoy Rhea. Bye-bye. I said you're a game? Oh, sorry. Sorry for redirecting,
but there's no other way to remember on, okay? Bye-bye. Bye-bye.